you enjoy Martini on the train and you
get there in about 3 hours it's a much
better way to move so do Californians
want to do that my answer is yes I hope
their answer is yes even if Californians
still want High-Speed Rail after 15
years of government mismanagement and
pouring $20 billion down the drain they
shouldn't hold out hope the planned rail
line connecting Los Angeles and San
Francisco is stuck in planning and
construction yet it just got another
$200 million from the federal go whoops
I mean taxpayers the cost of the project
has ballooned from an estimated $33
billion to about 128 billion the CEO of
the California highspeed rail Authority
says even that's not enough we need to
spend about between 80 and 100 million a
month if you do the math on that divide
that by 30 days it's even you know more
than 3 million a day large government
funded infrastructure projects never pan
out the way they are supposed to so it's
probably best for Californians to just
enjoy their martinis at home